ماذا تقول للأشخاص الذين يقولون أن
الصيغة الأولى
لا ينبغي أن تعمل مع
المملكة العربية السعودية بلد يستخدم
الرياضة للتستر على
انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان
جيدًا أه أقول لهم تعلمون أن الصيغة
الأولى حكيمة بما يكفي لمعرفة ما هو
جيد
أه من أجل  هم وسمعتهم ، وإذا
شعروا أن المملكة العربية السعودية هي
واحدة من تلك البلدان التي
لم يوافقوا أبدًا على القدوم إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
، فلا يكفي لأي شخص
أن يحكم على بلد أو أمة بمجرد
قراءة أشياء
من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
و  الكثير من الأشياء ، معظمهم من
الأشياء التي يقولون إنها ليست صحيحة أو غير صحيحة
ربما كانت في الماضي
ولكن الآن خاصة فيما يتعلق بحقوق المرأة
إذا أتيت إلى السعودية ورأيت
دور المرأة الآن وماذا تفعل
في المملكة العربية السعودية
ليس الأمر
وكأنك تقول ذلك قبل 20 أو أه 10 أو 5 سنوات ، لكن
منذ بضعة أشهر فقط كانت لدينا
قصص مثل قصة لوجان
التي سُجنت لأكثر من ألف
يوم بسبب حملتها
ضد حظر المملكة لقيادة النساء.  rs
نعم ولكن هذا هو
السبب الوحيد لسجنها لمجرد أنها
تتحدث عن سبب عدم
قيادة النساء للقيادة ، لا أعتقد أن هذا
هو السبب وراء وجود الكثير من الأشياء
وراء قول منظمة مراقبة حقوق الإنسان
أن النساء  لا يزال اعتقال الناشطة الحقوقية لوجان هات
ومعاملتها من قبل السلطات السعودية
بمثابة
إجهاض صارخ للعدالة ،
ولا تزال الأسئلة تُطرح حول وفاة
الصحفي جمال خاشقجي ، والتي خلص إليها مراسل الأمم المتحدة
الخاص أغنيس كالامار بأنها
تشكل جريمة قتل خارج نطاق القضاء ارتكبتها
دولة مملكة المملكة العربية السعودية.  المملكة
العربية السعودية مسؤولة
عن مقتل جمال خاشقجي لا يزال
يمثل
وصمة عار
على المملكة العربية السعودية.
كيف تعتقد
أن عرقك سيغير
ذلك
جيدًا.
ما حدث لجمال خاشقجي
مأساة أعلم أن المملكة العربية السعودية كانت
تعرف الكثير من الأشياء المتعلقة
بحقوق الإنسان  لكن في حالة اغتيال أو قتل
شخص كان هذا شيئًا صادمًا بالنسبة
لنا خاصة
حيث قُتل وكيف
قُتل هذا  شيء
صدمنا جميعًا ولا نتوقع أبدًا
شيئًا
كهذا يخرج من السعوديين خاصةً السعوديين
الرسميين ،
يجب أن أسألك قبل السباق في
البحرين العام الماضي ، لويس هاميلتون كما
تعلمون ، بطل العالم سبع مرات ، أحد
الشخصيات البارزة في الفورمولا واحد تحدث.
ضد مشكلة حقوق الإنسان ، معتبرة أن
الصيغة الأولى لديها مشكلة كبيرة ومتسقة
تحتاج إلى معالجتها مع انتهاكات
حقوق الإنسان في البلدان
التي تزورها ، ما مدى قلقك من أن لويس قد يتصدى لقضايا في المملكة
العربية
السعودية ، لست قلقًا أه على الإطلاق
تعرفه مع لويس  هاميلتون أنت تعرف أنني
أحترمه حقًا كسائق وأنا
معجب بما يفعله ولديه كل
الحق وليس فقط السائقين
الآخرين للتحدث كما تعلم كما قلت في المملكة
العربية السعودية لقد غيرنا الكثير
إلى الإيجابي هناك  الكثير من الحرية
وحقوق الإنسان أه
أعتقد أن شيئًا نأخذه على محمل الجد ،
هل ستكون منفتحًا على الاجتماع
معه لمناقشة هذه القضايا معه ،
نعم بالتأكيد أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنا كبير
معجبي لويس ونريده أن يأتي
حتى
قبل أن يأتي ذلك ليرى
رأيه رأي
الجميع يهمنا لقد التقيت بالفرق التي التقيت بها
مع السائقين ، وكان لديهم
وجهة نظر مختلفة وغادروا
من منظور إيجابي ،
لذلك نحن واثقون جدًا من
أنه ليس لدينا أي شيء نخفيه إذا كان
لدينا شيء نخفيه في المملكة العربية السعودية ،
فلماذا نفتح
بلادنا ونجلب الناس
ليروا أه
من نحن حقًا إذا كان لدينا
شيء نخفيه أو إذا أردنا أن نغسل شيئًا رياضيًا ،
فلن
نسمح للناس بالمجيء ومعرفة من نحن